each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
but so we are very fortunate to have
real knowledge coming from from West
Virginia and she's going to talk about
rehabilitation using connecting the
rehabilitation process thank you thanks
thanks so much for having me here so I
do live on the other side of the country
right now but i actually did my
undergraduate work in Washington just
down the road in Tacoma so it's good to
be back to my pseudo home or what was my
home for five years not too long ago so
hopefully I can kind of keep everybody's
attention I know we may all be in that
kind of post lunch lag right now but i
really want to share with you some of
the research we've been doing and in
particular the research i've been doing
for my thesis which is really directed
at using the Kinect for two purposes and
Stroke stroke motor improvements and
that is really first the assessment of
stroke patients and their initial motor
deficits and kind of tracking their
improvements or in some cases decline
over time but then also using the Kinect
in one step further and kind of as a
rehabilitation device so just to give
you an idea since I think most of you
are kind of familiar faces to each other
and you probably all know what the u-dub
campus looks like but just to give you
an idea i am at West Virginia University
I am technically in the center for
neuroscience although we also are kind
of interdisciplinary with the physical
therapy department so that nice glass
building is kind of where I call my home
right now and we're located within a
subdivision of the Center for
neuroscience which is actually a
clinical translational Stroke Center
this Center was developed not too long
ago but we span everything from human
clinical translational work all the way
down to more molecular and genetic
mechanisms of stroke so we have a really
nice breakfast depth of research groups
that are kind of all involved in this
stroke center we like to say that we
have the opportunity to study stroke
patients because we are one of the
highest states at risk and incidence of
stroke which gives us a great patient
population to pull from so good
opportunity for us maybe not a great
opportunity for some of the people who
live there but in either case west
virginia university
which we are actually fortunate enough
to be physically attached to so it makes
it really easy to get access to both
patients neurologists and clinicians
Ruby Hospital which is our West Virginia
University Hospital is the only stroke
certified Center in West Virginia so
anytime a patient has a stroke in West
Virginia is upon entry to the emergency
department in it whatever county or city
local hospital they have if somebody
thinks they're having a stroke there
immediately life flighted to our
hospital so again huge population of
patients for us to pool from which is
really allowed the research that we're
conducting to really be possible since
we do have this great breadth of patient
population we're also really fortunate
that we have great access to our
neurologist and physical therapist so we
have these monthly meetings they're
always available to help and kind of
talk and collaborate with me and my p.i
as well whenever we need them but this
is really enabled us to kind of drive
our research to meet clinical needs we
have no interest in developing another
tool that clinicians and physical
therapists have no interest or no need
to use right because waste everybody's
time and money and there's just really
no point in it so to give you an idea
I'm just kind of a basic overview of
what our lab does I'm a graduate student
in the neural engineering and
rehabilitation lab and in general our
focus is kind of twofold one to
understand the underlying mechanisms of
motor control so how do we go from
wanting to make a movement to our
central and peripheral nervous systems
working together to integrate develop a
plan and then carry out that plan in an
effective action we're also really
interested in looking at how these
mechanisms change with neurological
injury so what are kind of the
underlying mechanisms that cause
somebody who's had a stroke to kind of
present with these typical phenotypes we
see in these motor impairments we see
and we'd like to take what we learn from
both healthy individuals and those who
have suffered from a stroke and kind of
combine that scientific evidence to
really build and help improve
rehabilitation practices and that's
really what drives the majority of
research that goes on in our lab so how
do we do this I'm sure most of you are
familiar with most of these tools but
motion capture equipment we use in the
lab we use an active LED system which is
our face
base impulses stem so we have 18 camera
set up in our lab we can put anywhere
from 36 to 48 LEDs on an individual to
get full body motion capture fantastic
temporal resolution so we can record at
480 frames a second and we get sub
millimeter precision spatial accuracy we
also obviously use the Kinect which is a
lot of the research I'm going to be
talking about today for electromyography
or muscle activity recordings we have
two systems we use our delsea system
which is a wireless system when we want
to look at patients kind of interacting
an environment or moving around a space
we also we also have our motion lab
system which is a wired system the
benefit to this system even though it is
a little bit more cumbersome is the fact
that we can synchronize everything
incredibly well so between our kinematic
and our dynamic information we're
getting we have fantastic
synchronization we can also synchronize
it with our transcranial magnetic
stimulator that we use so for those of
you who are not familiar TMS
transcranial magnetic stimulation
basically takes advantage of magnetic
fields and when you pulse this thing it
activates a portion of the cortext over
what you're hovering we have two types
of coils the coil I have here in the
picture is more of a v-shaped coil so it
actually is shaped like this and what
that allows us to do is penetrate deeper
into the soul side to the areas of the
motor cortex that are more in control of
your lower legs we also have a flat coil
which is more shaped like this and that
can stimulate the more peripheral areas
of the motor cortex so we can target
upper body function the beauty of the
TMS is it allows us to really look at
how the motor cortex is directly
interacting with specific movements so
as somebody's moving we can use the TMS
to stimulate the corticospinal tract and
really look at the involvement there of
the motor cortex in the movement we also
are kind of new fancy piece of equipment
we've been kind of integrated into our
lab is we recently got a vertex split
belt treadmill this is integrated with a
MTI force plates so we get fantastic
force data while being able to
manipulate these belts individually of
each other for speed so we're doing a
lot of studies looking at kind of
perception of difference in speed speed
difference between the
two legs and again we can kind of
combined all these or kind of attempt to
as synchronize Lee as possible record
all this data at once we also use the
oculus rift which is a 3d goggle set up
so it actually kind of looks like
snowboarding goggles that are all
enclosed and this is great for immersive
3d environments we use the Vizard system
as kind of our platform to build these
virtual environments so what a lot of
our experiments involve is having
individuals reach two different targets
and so the way we do that instead of
having to have this big contraption in
front of them is we actually project the
targets in 3d space the beauty and kind
of of what we do is once we put LEDs on
somebody's arm now they can see their
arm actually move in space in that 3d
helmet so we kind of have this
representation stick figure so they
actually feel like they're really
touching and reaching to the targets Joe
I think makes it a lot more realistic I
probably don't have to go over this
hearing some of the talks today I think
we're pretty all comfortable with what
motor impairment is but again it's
something just important to keep keep in
mind when we're designing both
assessment rehabilitation protocols we
have to understand that motor
impairments are very variable so they
can affect just one limb or multiple
limbs and the etiology of these diseases
can really be different so even though
somebody two individuals may be
presenting with similar motor deficits
how those motor deficits are really
arising in the individual can be
dramatically different and I think
that's really important to understand
when you're trying to treat those motor
impairments okay so since I'm going to
be talking about stroke I just want to
give you a little bit of background on
some of the statistics as well as on
what a stroke is so this is not just a
problem in America globally there's
roughly 15 million individuals will
suffer from a stroke each year it's the
second leading cause of death and
disability globally when we look at it
within the United States there's roughly
800,000 strokes that occur each year
it's become the leading cause of death
and the leading cause of adult
disability and its projected or
estimated that we spend roughly seventy
four billion dollars a year treating
both the acute and long-term effects of
stroke so obviously this is a pretty
pertinent problem right now so for those
of you
who don't know although probably
comfortable saying most of us do you
know here what a stroke is but we can
kind of think of it as a heart attack of
the brain so specifically there's two
types of strokes we see ischemic and
hemorrhagic ischemic strokes are far
more prevalent they cover about
eighty-seven percent of all strokes and
this is where there is a blockage of a
blood vessel in the brain so again when
you develop a blood clot somewhere in
your body and it's thrown or carried to
a portion of the brain and it cuts off a
portion of blood supply to an area of
the cortex hemorrhagic strokes on the
other hand are slightly less common but
can be as devastating as an ischemic and
this is a rupture of a blood vessel
which then leaks the blood into the
surrounding area of the tissue size and
location of strokes obviously vary
widely but size does not always mean
severity so you can have a very small
stroke but if it's in a really crucial
part of your cortex it could impact you
just as severely as somebody who's had a
very large or broad stroke one important
thing that we talked a lot about as far
as kind of initial assessment or
tracking patients in the more acute
phases of the strokes of the first 48 72
hours after stroke is the difference
between core and penumbra tissue so a
core of a stroke is really the immediate
area or the immediate cells that have
been damaged or killed off by that
stroke the penumbra is more of this
surrounding area here and this tissue is
kind of the at-risk tissue for becoming
kind of enveloped into that core area so
a lot of the acute treatments that are
kind of projected or researched for
stroke acute stroke treatment really
focus on salvaging as much of that
penumbra tissue as possible and really
limiting the size of that core because
in the long term the less amount of
tissue you can lose the better prognosis
and the better outcome the patient will
have so acute kind of treatment or
assessment of a stroke again when
somebody comes into a emergency room and
is presenting with stroke like symptoms
they may have a very basic neurological
exam and if a neurologist or clinician
thinks they are in fact having a stroke
the most typical second step will be a
radiological assessment at West Virginia
University in particular we start with a
CT scan then move on to an MRI
and if it's deemed necessary and this
will really tell you a kind of location
of the stroke and perhaps severity of
the stroke if you can get at that
information to treat a stroke acutely so
once somebody's in the emergency room
you've deemed that they are in fact
having a stroke you kind of have to
treatment options as of right now you
can use TPA tissue plasminogen activator
which is given through an IP injection
travels to the side of the clot and
basically just works to dissolve that
clot up return blood flow to the area
the other thing that's being used right
now is in the canticle device there's
several different types but just to give
you an idea this little cathode is
snaked up through a major artery they
basically find the site of the clot and
then through either a balloon or a kind
of twisting mechanism attached onto the
clot retrieve it and again the idea is
to return blood flow to that area that
is on is lacking blood so when we talk
about initial stroke assessment one of
the things commonly used again kind of
in the emergency room setting is the NIH
Stroke Scale this is a very broad scale
covers everything from speech and
language to ability to swallow two very
very generalized motor functions so they
really just look at upper vs. lower
extremity function doesn't give a lot of
motor detail but this can kind of tell a
neurologist maybe where somebody is
initially and they can track it in the
24 48 72 hours post-stroke now when we
talk about specific deficits associated
with a stroke we kind of have two broad
phenotypes that we look at so we have
the spasticity or this increased muscle
tone and this obviously leads to
problems such as being able to grasp an
object or release an object decreases
fluidity in motion as well as range of
motion hemiplegia is the other kind of
typical phenotype we see and this is
more of your flaccid paralysis and as
we've talked about earlier in older
adults especially who have this
hemiplegia after stroke this really
leads to an increased susceptibility to
Falls after a stroke but again it's
important to kind of keep these
phenotypes in mind when we're developing
both assessments and rehabilitation
tools because certain patients are going
to have different levels of kind of
general motor impairment right after
their stroke
okay so when we're talking about initial
assessments a lot of the tools that have
kind of been developed to initially
assess motor function of a stroke
patient really have maybe been developed
more for research purposes or research
tools to kind of look at effectiveness
of a treatment over time some of the
problems associated with these
assessments sorry that that's cut off
there but it's just the title some of
the problems associated with these is
the fact that they're very wide range as
to what they're actually looking at so
some of these assessments focus more on
ability to kind of manipulate fine
objects whereas other assessments might
look at more broad range functional
activities of daily living some of the
benefits though to these assessments is
that again they can be a really useful
research tool so when we want to look at
the effectiveness of a treatment
paradigm we can use one of these these
assessments to kind of get an initial
idea of where the patients at and then
look at their progress over time the
drawbacks to these is the fact that
we're really not sure if they're
capturing these underlying motor
deficits that they have after a stroke
so again when you're asking a stroke
patient to lift a cup and you're
measuring their ability to lift the cup
are you really seeing what is underline
that motor deficit are you just looking
at their ability to lift a cup also the
scores they can sometimes be vague and
they're not often used consistently in a
clinical setting so if you're not
tracking a patient's progress over time
using a kind of standard assessment how
are you really knowing if the treatment
a rehabilitation paradigm you're
providing that patient is really working
also a lot of these assessments can be
lengthy and they can be difficult to
perform whether it's due to the size of
area you need to perform the assessment
or the specific tools you need to
perform the assessment so again benefits
and drawbacks but our idea is really to
kind of meet the needs of both
clinicians and patients to develop some
sort of assessment and rehabilitation
tool that may be better able to kind of
character characterize some of these
underlying motor impairments so I kind
of have the project that we're working
on right now broken up into four aims in
ames one and two I'm going to be
focusing more on the assessment side of
things whereas aims three and four a
little bit more geared towards the long
from rehabilitation of these stroke
patients okay so the first thing we
wanted to do was again we need to come
up with a tool that's low cost and can
be used clinically as we talked about
earlier today we have these fantastic
motion capture systems but to put them
in every clinic clinic seems a little
bit not very feasible and they're very
expensive and the number of personnel
and how well the personnel have to be
trained to get information out of those
systems really can be quite cumbersome
so the idea we kind of had was okay well
let's find a better option let's find
something that's easier to use and is
more low-cost while the Kinect obviously
prevent presents itself well to both of
those options so our first idea was to
compare how well the Kinect can capture
kinematics compared to a
state-of-the-art system and that was
really the first kind of general goal of
this first aim we also wanted to
determine if we could use an automated
algorithm to actually score a stroke
patients motor ability so again this is
kind of our face based system here
active LED system that we are that we
use to compare against the Kinect so
what we did is we had ten stroke
patients perform movements that are
based on clinical assessments that the
movements we have been performed are
illustrated down here in this diagram
dish kind of shows the actual difference
in positioning of the active markers the
LED markers versus where the Kinect
tracks the human body and we recorded as
we had our stroke patients perform these
movements we recorded them
simultaneously with the Kinect and with
the facespace system after we recorded
that data we calculated joint angles of
the shoulder elbow and wrist and then we
could basically compared kinematic or
motion capture ability between those two
systems so if we look at the average
error between the two motion capture
systems this was across all of our
patients in all ten movements we see
that we get an average difference
between the face space in the Kinect
system for shoulder flexion extension of
fourteen percent shoulder abduction
adduction of twelve percent elbow
flexion extension of two percent and
wrist flexion extension of seven percent
14 and 12% may seem maybe on the larger
side of things as far as an average
difference between the two systems but
was really more intriguing is the fact
that those averages were pretty
consistent across all of our patients
the benefit to this is as long as we
know that the two systems have a a
verrin stats fairly consistent it really
shouldn't actually affect this scoring
that we did later on with the kinematic
data so again then we wanted to
determine if we could use the facespace
in motion-capture connect systems to
automate the scoring of a strokes stroke
patients motor impairment so in plot a
what we have here along this line here
along the x-axis are the scores derived
from the facespace motion capture system
compared to the scores derived from the
Kinect system again we had a pretty good
linear relationship between the two
suggesting that the two systems
basically the kinematics they were
extracting were comparable to create
this quantitative score we developed we
also then compared the Kinect scores
which is now on the x axis to the
qualitative scores these qualitative
scores were generated from 30 physical
therapy students rating each one of our
patients movements so we would video
record each of our patients do you
identify them by basically blurring out
their face and then we had 30 physical
therapy students rate the patient's
movements on the on a 02 to scale and
that's what we used for comparing to our
our connect based scoring system another
interesting thing we found from this
data was when we look at inner class
correlation coefficient or basically how
well the human raters are performing
compared to our system we found that it
was usually about an average of three
human raters that it took to get a
comparable score to our computer based
algorithm so this suggests that perhaps
it could provide a more accurate score
than one or two physical therapy
students and maybe could perform better
in a clinical setting so the second kind
of wave of this research then was to
determine if we could use this automated
algorithm we've to
to really automate a clinical assessment
so for this we chose the wolf motor
function test if you're not familiar
with it this consists of roughly 17
movements that are pretty typical of
activities of daily living we did omit
two movements just for some feasibility
purposes but we had ten stroke patients
perform the wolf motor function test
with both are affected and unaffected
Lin and we recorded them while they were
moving with the Kinect again we had
physical therapy students rate their
movements on the zero to five now scale
that the wolf motor function test uses
and then we compared our automated
algorithm to the performance of those
physical therapy students so to give you
an idea of actually how our algorithm
works what we do is once we've
calculated the joint angle data for both
the affected and unaffected arm we use a
decomposition analysis and really what
this does is it pulls out the major kind
of trends or the major variance in the
data so I kind of go through this
step-by-step hopefully it'll make as
much sense as possible so the solid
lines that I have represented all these
graphs are the actual kinematics we
recorded from the connect the dashed
lines are the reconstructed movement
that we get from extracting two
principal components from the unaffected
arm so what we do is we extract these
principal components here and then we
reconstruct the affected arm movement
and then what we use is we use
correlation coefficients to quantify how
similar or in some cases how different
that reconstruction was from the
original data set and what that allows
us to do is really quantify difference
in movement ability between the two arms
so in the top plot here this section
here we have us mildly impaired patient
who really didn't have a lot of
difference in motor ability between
their two limbs this individual would
have received a high score on our
quantitative algorithm whereas if you
compare it with a more severely impaired
patient you can see here they have
pretty little to almost no movement
ability in their affected arm in this
patient the difference between the
effect and unaffected limbs would be
greater so they'd get a lower score on
our quantitative algorithm if we look at
the overall observations between our
quantitative score
which are now here on the y-axis in the
scores from the physical therapy
students they actually get a
surprisingly good relationship between
the two one thing we did notice and
through talking with some physical
therapists and actually talking with dr.
wolf who unbeknownst to him that test
was named after him he didn't actually
develop that test which was kind of
interesting but what typically happens a
lot is we get these floor and ceiling
effects here so if i can get my pointer
so it's really easy to give somebody a 5
which is perfect movement or a zero or
one which is almost no movement but it's
really hard to kind of delineate in
between so what we see is a lot of our
patients kind of we're given these
scores of that averaged out somewhere
between four and a half and five but we
see a lot bigger difference in our
quantitative algorithm we don't think
that that's because the quantitative
algorithm isn't working well we actually
think that's because that this is based
off of kinematic recordings it's
actually picking up some of them minut
differences that a human may not be able
to detect just through eyesight the
other important consideration for the
wolf motor function test test is that
there's a time domain associated with it
so all the patients are recorded on
their time to perform each test so we
wanted to make sure that our automated
algorithm could also detect onset and
offset a movement and what we did for
this was just basically used a kind of
simple velocity threshold detection
method again we saw a pretty good
correlation between that and the time
domain found by human physical therapist
so again those were kind of the two
assessment based research research tasks
that we've taken on and again we really
want to kind of alleviate some of the
cost and time constraints that cause
these assessments to not be used on a
consistent basis in the clinic we also
want to provide this more quantitative
measure for motor impairment so really
kind of make some sort of defining
numeric scale basically of which you can
measure a stroke patients improvement
over time ok so moving away from the
assessment side then and getting more
into the rehabilitation side aims three
and four were much
or are much more geared towards looking
at long-term rehabilitation using the
Kinect so some of the things we want to
address in ames 3 & 4 or to track
patients improvements but also to
improve specific joint angle scores so
right now we'd get one score for the
patient we'd actually like to get scores
for specific degrees of freedom at each
joint we'd also like to eventually bring
this care into patient's home and kind
of develop this network for
rehabilitation which I'll get into more
in a second so I'm sure many of you know
for any kind of rehabilitation the more
often you can provide the rehabilitation
and the earlier on in the injury you can
provide the rehabilitation will provide
the best long-term outcomes there's been
a lot of recent improvements in
technology that we kind of all have been
discussing today and a lot of these
recent improvements in technology are
now being incorporated into
rehabilitation efforts so motion capture
accelerometers and gaming systems we've
kind of already gone over some of the
concerns associated with rehabilitation
again I'm probably kind of preaching to
the choir here but time and cost home
compliance is a big issue in West
Virginia in particular we have a large
rural population and it makes it really
difficult for these patients to travel
to Morgantown which is where the
University Hospital is to get their
treatment so some of the possible
solutions may be to implement the Kinect
type system in a home for home
rehabilitation or telehealth telehealth
networking and also to provide patients
with interactive games that might help
boost this home compliance issue so
again like I mentioned before possible
ways to address some of these concerns
it really needs to be something that's
easy to use and is low-cost we all kind
of are facing this issue right now of
insurance companies are getting stricter
and stricter for what they want to pay
so cost associated concerns are really
kind of at the forefront right now so
one idea we had was to kind of develop
this wheel and spoke Network which
basically would act as having a couple
centralized physical therapists who
could kind of monitor patients in real
time in this kind of spoke spoke like
system
so aim 3 this is a future direction
we're kind of gearing up to get started
right now is to now take this automated
system we've started studying in the lab
and actually bring it into a clinical
setting sorry that that's kind of cut
off there but what we would like to do
is set up this system in a clinic and
actually assess patients upon arrival
prior to seeing the clinician and so
when the clinician actually goes in to
meet with the patient the clinician
already has a printout of a score of the
of the individuals motor impairment we
then want to record this information
over visits and then examine these
long-term outcomes from tracking their
improvements over time aim for which is
another future direction we are moving
in the direction of now is more of this
home monitoring and rehabilitation
system so again using this kind of wheel
and spoke approach we want to set up
these connect like systems in
individuals home so they could actually
do this rehabilitation while being
monitored in real time by a physical
therapist we also want to provide them
with some interactive games and one idea
we had to was to kind of again boost
home compliance is maybe set up a
network where these patients could
actually play these games against each
other we all kind of know that
competition drives a lot of things so if
we could give these individuals and
these patients and competition through
playing with each other through these
online games maybe that would help kind
of boost their compliance okay this is
kind of a random little side note here
but recently we our lab was visited by
the prime minister of health care from
Estonia so Estonia is a very small
country which I actually had no idea
where to be honest where it was even
geographically located but it's roughly
almost the same population size as West
Virginia and they also have an extremely
high rural population so what is stoning
it by the way if you want to know one
interesting fact about Estonia that's
where we got skype from so thank them
for skype but what they have really
moved to because of these high rural
populations is that they are really now
relying on telehealth care so in these
more rural communities they're really
relying on kind of this internet network
to provide health care to their
individuals so we see this as kind of an
in
steen case study of hopefully eventually
this is where we could kind of move to
in the United States providing patients
with more in home rehabilitation and
therapy options kind of my last thing I
always like to to remark especially when
talking to clinicians is the fact that
we are not trying to replace physical
therapists we are simply trying to
provide them with a tool that would help
assist them do their job and provide
better long-term outcomes to the
patients one of the kind of one of the
comments we get a lot from physical
therapist is well this system is going
to put me out of a job physical
therapists will never be out of a job we
all know that you always need a person
to be there and interact with the
patient we really just want to provide a
tool that would kind of help alleviate a
lot of the problems that they're having
and the patients are having as well so
with that I just want to acknowledge the
members of my lab my p.i dr. gritsenko
the postdoc in our lab talker dr.
Talkington as well as our lab tech who
does a lot of the 3d programming for our
virtual reality system Brad Pollard in
our collaborator suru yo vengo who works
with us on our human projects as well as
does some animal modeling for us and
then the funding of my fellowship so
that's all I'll take questions yeah
differentiation is a movement that you
can naturally show the Kinect like
standing in one place in
some gates analysis that you can do I
mean think this would be restricted on
the side of the neck so I don't know
what's potentially so you mean kind of
the ability to use different types of
kinematic data and the scoring algorithm
or any blood people will study in one
place right people you would run into
the world right yes selection of the
device itself right Oh what will how
does it connect these strokes analysis
of different conditions so that's one
other aspect that we really want to
eventually get into is trying to see if
we can expand maybe not this algorithm
in particular but an algorithm like it
to kind of capture a broader range of
neurological injuries that create these
or cause motor impairments as far as the
clinical issue so some of the concerns
and things right off the bat we've had
to address with putting this in a clinic
is first of all you're going to have to
be very specific as to where you set up
the connect and where you instruct the
patient to stand because we know there's
kind of this sweet spot with the Kinect
if you're too close it doesn't work
you're too far away it doesn't work if
you're moving a lot side to side it
might not work as well something else we
have to think about is what if we have
an individual who comes in with a
wheelchair is that now going to kind of
interfere with the recording of the
kinect or will it be able to pick it up
as well so we still have you know we
still have some room to improve and some
different tests we need to look at and
different patient populations we need to
look at
because the 1770 trials of the world
test not engage no it's all upper body
function it does make it easy um when
you look at the upper body versus the
lower body obviously gate is nice to
study because it's in a healthy
individual is very symmetric whereas the
upper body you kind of have many more
degrees of freedom you can kind of
explore with your arms but on the other
hand of that when you're just looking at
upper body you can have somebody be
fairly stationary to assess their motor
function of their upper body or as if
you're looking at lower leg motor
function you need to kind of have them
engaging a larger area of workspace the
time pointing it's easy the connectives
is starting I mean it will be easier is
it relatively easy to look at the hopper
particle mm-hmm but if you try to look
at lower but in running through into the
device mutation right so
what I'm essentially asking is whether
this is going to be meet you in your
attempt to use home based reputation so
as of the way the the device and the
algorithm sits right now yes it's we are
limited to looking just at upper body
function I think there is absolutely
room room to improve on that both on the
technological and hardware and software
side of things as well as the algorithm
we're looking using to look at upper
body function may not be the best
algorithm to look now at lower body
function so I think we need to kind of
expand some of our research ideas to
look at that if we really want to
integrate this in a home it would make
more sense that it could assess both
lower and upper body function at once
not just one or the other yeah always so
my PhD in particular is in neuroscience
um I actually have a pretty strong
background in physical therapy though my
p.i doctor gets anko and our
collaborator Sergey have been doing a
lot of the kind of programming to take
some of the SDK packages and develop
them into these standalone systems but
as scientists you always kind of run
into this problem of you want to do a
lot of things but certain things take a
lot of time so if we had somebody who
maybe was a little bit more geared on
computer science side of things we could
probably develop and then and then test
a lot of these algorithms a lot faster
so time constraints everything is time
and money yeah so you said you're gonna
have I decided McClintock bring your
hips like a certain room for them or you
should have in the waiting room and we
expect the challenges that yeah so what
our idea is to set up basically is to
have this in a kind of a separate
waiting room area where just one patient
would go in at a time then you're going
to eliminate a lot of the issues with
people walking behind and opening doors
so the idea is that kind of the
conceptual view we have right now is the
patient would show up it would check in
the nurse would come and get them and
escort them to this room they would do
the assessment the nurse could either
sit and wait in the room while they were
doing it just make sure
no technical difficulties and then as
the patient was then waiting for the
clinician to have their actual physical
therapy appointment the scores would
kind of be sent or printed out so that
the clinician could have those prior to
seeing the patient sorry just follow so
just for usability same you plan to have
any sort of survey questions or
interview questions or has some big
serve them see what their experience is
like if they find an intrusive yeah yeah
so we need to do a lot of investigation
into how patients are going to perceive
this but also what we would like to do
is kind of expand it so this could also
be type of a a type of survey and motor
assessment system so when they show up
they could have questions to answer
first like well what is your average
pain on a daily on a daily basis are you
having trouble navigating through your
home have you fallen recently those
kinds of things we could kind of build
in some extra information into this
generalized assessment was it quite sure
this algorithm that you used to create
the score from the connect so they came
in he did this wolf of infirmity battery
yeah okay and that's got a score into it
but then he's in his said you had this
algorithm that the connect did the same
score or how did that what was the
algorithm that the connect the automatic
how did it arrive at its ok so what we
do is we have a physical therapy therapy
students rate our subjects once we
collect the kinematic data from the from
the connect I'm going the wrong way we
calculate joint angles and then we use
that information to then extract the
principal components for it so right now
this is all done kind of post analysis
in MATLAB and that's one of the other
areas we need to kind of focus on is to
make this make all those analysis strips
automated into the eventual software
that will work with that Hardware
describe this
the pc yes pca on shoulder abduction and
children flexion extension outboard so
four degrees of freedom yeah yeah so we
hit pulley up to yeah yeah because if we
pulled out four principal components we
would probably get the exact four angles
that we are getting from the unaffected
arm so we're looking for the two
principal components that are explaining
the most amount of variance in all four
ankles and then I guess the piece i miss
Mia's we're at Malcolm end using those
and entertain the leaf vento applying
this to the paretic arms okay and what
that yeah show so so that means
something when we extract the principal
components we're assuming that these two
principal components and based on
basically the mathematics used to do
this decomposition analysis that these
two principal components are
representing the most amount of variance
from those for joint angles so when we
take those two components and then we
then reconstruct affected arm data we
want to see if there's a high
correlation between the reconstructed
reconstructed data in the original
recorded data then we know that the two
limbs were moving fairly similar yeah
and if we can't reconstruct the data
well for the paretic arm then we know
that there was a large difference in
motor function between the two limbs
because now that the variance that is
explained for the unaffected lamb is no
longer explaining the variance for the
affected length and then there is where
you kind of it to get the score yeah
Pinkel ways
of your deal
but just sergeant sendak so basically
what you're trying to measure is kind of
the much simply between the two arm
right so it's not as if you saying that
there is a right way from this current
you're saying we're looking at the
similarity of movement between the two
lens yeah so it's like an gate you can
compare to this databases yeah I'm in
creating the difference ya hear
everyone's going to do it slightly
differently compared to their to their
critics right to their unaffected on
should give talk you had the when you
measure the accuracy of angle what would
be kind of what would be good a crazy
like you know zero percent difference is
again I think maybe I mean obviously if
you're having a on average of fifty
percent difference between a
state-of-the-art system in a low-cost
system like the connect that's going to
raise a lot of red flags as to how well
your your motion capture is actually
working I think what maybe is though
more important than the percentage is
how consistent that difference is and
that really may speak more towards how
the points of rotation are being
actually calculated by the Kinect and
the actual skeleton fit of the kinect so
as long as that that difference between
face space and connect joint angles is
pretty consistent then it's then it's
just basically a built-in difference
into how those joint angles are being
calculating is it fair to say that was
you
you can see more for bias and variance
so there's kind of bias yeah I guess
yeah that would be a good way to
describe it yeah quantitative measures
did you get from so the quantitative
measures are these so basically this
quantitative score and instance we're
using correlation coefficients it says
it's a 0 to 1 it's basically an
r-squared value that we're getting that
when we're comparing those two
reconstructed in original joint angles
so let's